okay so thank you very much all for
coming um
so the title of the talk is beyond
pandas the great python data frame shout
out and we're going to talk about a few
things so first i'm going to make a bit
longer introduction about myself and get
a bit more context about why we're
giving this talk in the context of what
we do at the company i work for
i'm going to talk a little bit about
pandas but not too much just to
describe what are the
strong points of pandas but especially
the limitations that led to the rest of
the alternatives to develop
and then we're going to describe a few
of those alternatives in more detail
there will be a live demo as well so i
will pray to the like demo gods
for everything to go right
and then we will
do some conclusions
so first of all my name is juan luis i'm
an aerospace engineer with a passion for
math science coding and communities
especially python communities i'm a
self-taught
pythonista so bear with me
right now i'm working as a data
scientist advocate at orchest which is a
company creating an open source data
pipeline orchestrator
and i'm currently the organizer of the
pi data madrid monthly meetup so you
feel like going to madrid to give a talk
just talk to me
i've been contributing to the scipy and
paid ecosystem uh for quite a few years
and you can follow me on github
so first of all why we're giving this
talk so at orcas we're building uh
a tool to empower data scientists it's a
pipeline orchestrator that i'm going to
uh show you in a moment
for the demo but the topic of the talk
is not
data pipelines or anything like that
however we're always in touch with users
and there's
one thing that usually comes up it turns
out that etl elt however modality you
want to do for your data pipelines
uh it's
changing a lot in the recent years we're
noticing that
probably the extract and load steps of
it are being like more commoditized
there are more tools
to do it in a more streamlined fashion
things like that
but there's always a need to do some
custom transformations
that can be simple or can be super
complex depending on the use case
and so we set ourselves to answer
are we using the best tools available or
are our users using best tools available
for the task and we focused initially on
data frame libraries which is where all
this exploration and this research came
about
so first of all let's talk about pandas
um
can you raise your hand if you use
pandas in the last week
and yeah so you're part of this
beautiful chart here
that shows that pandas has been a
massive
driver in the growth of python
and for the past decade
and we all know
the good qualities of pandas like we
super flexible api lots of methods
super extensive documentation good
adapters
for csv formats sql
based databases and things like that
however there's a very interesting blog
post that i recommend you to check out
which is
the apache arrow and the 10 things i
hate about pandas written by the creator
of pandas west mckinney so he was
reflecting a few years after
creating the pandas library on its
success but also on some of the quirks
and limitations
some of which are not really easy to
address without making dramatic changes
in the api or the philosophy of the
library so my
more or less rigid summary of of those
are
grouped in these two so basically many
pandas operations don't take advantage
of multiple cores or query planning so
there has been some progress to
release the global interpreter log for
example in some core parts of pandas but
these efforts are a little bit their
genius and not all of the pandas
api it takes advantage of that
and then since the evaluation model is
eager every time you do like a chain or
a pipe of operations
you end up with lots of intermediate
copies of your data that you're not
really interested about
and that might create memory spikes or
general
performance hits whatever
and then on the other hand there are
some
decisions in the pandas api that that
lead to
less than ideal uh
use of memory so for example how string
and categories are handled
and
the lack of memory mapping for some of
its
input output
capabilities
and the way
missing data is handled as well even
though some of these are
changing their proposals to like make
pandas more efficient this respect since
it's a super established project it's
probably going to take some time
so
um there are now a few alternatives
to pandas with
different use cases in mind or different
objectives
so i made like a
representation of them and to avoid
making into intellectual property
trouble and i
didn't want to call it the magic
quadrant so instead they call it the
charming quadrangle so here you have a
few of these alternatives we're mostly
going to focus
on the lower right
quadrant so what happens if you have
your queries about
whether you could do things different
in a different way as they are done in
pandas nowadays and i'm going to mention
very briefly uh the other
quadrants up there
so first of all there's apache arrow
which is the
um
the framework that was makini co-created
using the lessons the lessons learned
from the pandas
development
and it advertises itself as a language
independent color memory format there's
a few things to be said about this
though because there's a little bit of
confusion about whether it's
something that you store on disk or in
memory or what
so essentially there's like two
in-memory formats the streaming one and
the random access one the first one is
optimized for well streaming so you can
append to it
in an infinite fashion and the other one
is
more optimized for random access so the
the size of the buffers are fixed but in
return you get much better performance
and then i roll this arrow structures
can be serialized to disk
uh essentially in either apache parquet
which is probably the most
widely used format and feather which is
kind of the
arrow native disk format so to speak
it's uh written in c plus plus and
other languages as well so there's like
a few implementations and the python
binding bindings use the c plus plus
implementation and
we're going to see a little bit of code
of how arrow looks like so it's not
exactly an alternative but it works very
well as a foundation to create
alternative data frame libraries
then there's
vex i don't know who of you have used
vex
at some point yeah a few hands so it's
quite niche
and but it's a super interesting library
so again it advertises itself as out of
core data frames which means that it's
able to work with files that
don't fit into ram basically so
initially it was built around htf 5
which is more of a scientific data
format for
for labeled
n-dimensional arrays but then it gains
support for parkettes and many text
formats as well
it has some extra functionality for
large-scale
visualization so if you're like
visualizing clouds of points and things
like that that's super useful
and the api is more or less similar to
pandas although it deviates at some
points
we're going to see how
it leverages lazy evaluation as well
using an expression system
and finally there's polars i'm curious
how many people have used polars already
it's only me in the room this is uh oh
no there's two of us so
for me polars is the most interesting
one
of all this it's uh lightning fast in
memory data frames so in that sense it's
not really meant for
larger than run data sets
initially but if you can fit your data
in ram or read it in chunks or something
like that it provides a super
interesting api which is
based on expressions that can be
coupled together in a very generic way
and then it optimizes the query plan out
of this chain of expressions so that it
makes
memory use that is as efficient
as possible it's a very young library if
i
if i'm not mistaken
it started in the middle of the pandemic
so in may 2020
and but it's quite promising
and then so these three are like
libraries that don't have the objective
of b
being a drop-in replacement for pandas
but there are others that um
that could work in this way so you have
qdf for example from the rapids
ecosystem that
aims to be panda's own gpu so again if
you have a gpu on a single node and it's
probably going to accelerate the
processing by a quite a noticeable
factor there's dusk of course we had a
richard fantastic presentation yesterday
and the tutorial session so i'm not
going to
insist too much about it but
essentially is bringing pandas on a
distributed computing
context there are similar projects to
dusk like mars and ray and possibly
others
then there's modding which is a layer on
top of dusk that tries to
make
accelerating pandas as easy as possible
so just changing the import pandas spd
with import modding as pd and it works
and then of course there's spy spark
i've learned i
don't have any spark experience like
i only used it like seven years ago or
something but now it has gained a pandas
compatibility layer so in principle it
should be easier to like migrate a code
base although of course the
architecture and the internal
way of working is completely different
so i don't know how easy it is in
reality
okay so that was a bit of an overview of
what are the options available so let's
do some
demo here
let me see
okay so i have a few
um
blocks here that i'm going to fetch some
data for me so first i'm going to rerun
this
incoming
data fetching steps just to make sure
that i have
everything i need apparently everything
is working correctly
so i will going to give this a few
seconds
and then i'm going to go
one by one with
notebooks that i prefer so first of all
how to load data with pyro
and so
give me a second
[Music]
i hope this zoom is okay
there we go so i'm using the pyro 7.0
version here which is the most
recent one
and just as a showcase i'm starting with
the
super well-known new york taxi data set
that has
12 million rows only this
this one single file here so you can
imagine that if you download all the
years it's going to be quite a lot
so
as you can see pajaro has
csv reading
capabilities so you can use this read
csv file to load one of the internal
structures
and the first thing we notice is that we
have a schema with the column names and
what is the data type the in our there's
lots of rich data types that we can use
and
[Music]
also the other thing is that we didn't
really read the whole file into memory
now um no sorry the other way around but
we did um
read the
the whole file in memory we have now now
1.2 gigabytes more or less of resident
memory
um
and if you access one of the columns
from
from this structure you get something
called a chunked array which is the way
arrow organizes all the data internally
so that
it can be
processed
so again you can select a few columns if
you want you can filter the data
so
as you can see
the methods that it has are quite
different from pandas even though it can
convert back and forth
from
pandas instructors as well
okay so i'm going to skip this
and just to show you something that is a
little bit a little bit more interesting
i'm going to
open the other notebook that i have
which does some memory mapping
with a csv file there we go
and so instead of reading the whole file
into memory what we're going to do now
is to create a memory map which is a
technique that in a way reflects
the data that is on disk um in a way
that it doesn't need to be loaded
completely
in memory so if you see now we have
actually absolutely zero megabytes of
data allocated
we have this memory map uh handle that
it's at the b at the very beginning of
the file
and if we call the opencsv function now
with this memory mapping what we have is
that
um
arrow has advanced a little bit the file
so that it can infer the schema from the
columns and etc and from from the rest
everything is the same so i have all the
column names and the types and
everything
and i can do something like this so for
example i'm going to let this run and
then explain what it does what it does
so i'm opening a packet writer so i'm
going to transform all these csv data
into a parquet file and i can do that in
chunks so i'm reading the next batch
from the memory map that i created
before
then i am writing the batch to the
packet writer so this is converting all
the csv chunks on the fly to parquet
and then i'm iterating until i exhaust
the memory map basically and as you can
see at any single point we are only
allocating a very limited
um
memory size so this is super efficient
okay and that's done and by the way if
you are not using
parquet instead of csv files yet it's a
very good moment to do so because you
see originally this was 1.9 gigabytes
and now this is less than 0.5 gigabytes
so we saved quite a lot of space with
exactly the same information and
schemas that work so there's many
advantages here
and then i can load this packet file
again
i can see that it has exactly the same
schema as before and there's more
interesting things i can do which
include for example streaming chunks of
this data to
bytes io file or any other file like
interface that i want so this is very
good to exchange data between processes
between nodes and things like that
and yeah that's it
there we go
so that's about an
arrow
as you can see like
quite powerful but a bit low level as i
was saying so now i'm going to show a
little bit of vex
let me close this one
all right
so for the vex example i'm using a
different uh data set here the
airline delays data set which with data
that it's obtained from the bureau of
transportation from the government of
the u.s
and initially i'm only loading
one file there's one thing to be said
about vex though that was a little bit
surprising to me so i converted this to
parquet even though originally it was on
csv because otherwise the x converts
that under the hood to hdf5
and that filled my disk when i was first
trying this so now like i took the easy
route
and converted everything to parquet but
it's worth keeping that into account
so again this has like 7 million rows
more or less and i can display some
basic information about this data frame
like what are the columns and what are
the type of each column and things like
that
since original evx was created with
astronomical data in mind we have things
like physical units and and stuff like
that that are a little bit domain
specific
but again worth taking into account
and so
okay these are the column names and it
can do a dot describe like we would do
in pandas
um and etc so now how does this depart
from pandas well there's
a a concept called expressions i'm going
to keep this
maybe a few more seconds to finish or
probably i will
kill it
if i'm lucky well anyway
we're going to give it a few extra
seconds
so we have something called expressions
ah there we go
so when we access a particular column on
the data frame we don't actually
retrieve all the data
in memory but instead we get something
called an expression which is like a
proxy to all the lazy evaluation
capabilities of vex so for example if i
extract the carrier column here then we
have this information
but if i do mathematical operations with
such columns for example then there's
another expression being returned so we
see the last
five and the first five rows of the
result but this is not actually churning
over all the seven million rows and
executing the operation
this happens too if i put
the mathematical operation inside the
query as you can see this is a little
bit special so i can put actual upset
time minus
crs elapsed time and this gives me the
same expression as before
it works with numpy functions as well so
if i do like the square root
of an expression that also returns an
expression
and finally if i want to
execute
that expression
and i can do that in two ways i can
either just call an aggregation function
so that it returns some result
or i can even pass this progress equals
reach with which gives me
nice
progress
indicators that are very fun and amusing
to look at when you're a little bit
bored
and
if you have even more complex
expressions you can see that
it's now doing a series of operations is
computing the mean the sum the count
everything to give me and
this here in this case what are the the
delays of the non-canceled flights the
delays of the canceled flights
um
so that was for a single file and
vex has this capability similar to dusk
so you can open a series of files using
patterns like that
and in this case we would recover the
whole 61 million rows that this data set
has
and i can do the same operations it's
just that
the progress is going to be a little bit
slower but as you can see like it's
churning over 61 million rows quite
rapidly
and so in a couple of seconds this is
going to finish most likely
so there we go
and as i said and the other interesting
thing about vex is that it only it also
has some nice visualization capabilities
so if you're
visualizing very large chunks of data
this is something to look into as well
and i'm not too bad on time so i'm going
to now go over the last notebook that i
wanted to show you
which is the
bowlers one there we go
hello yes so
with polars i'm using yet another data
set by the way i didn't say that but all
of this is already online so you can
download it you can import it
so i'm using a dataset again from kaggle
which contains
uh i think it's a 10 sample of all the
stack overflow questions and answers and
tags which is quite interesting
and this is how the data set looks like
again polars has a read csv file
and that returns
a table here
and
you can see that i have the column names
the types of the columns so
for now this is not too different from
what we're used to
with pandas
it can display what's the first rows of
the tags data set
and all of these objects are also called
data frames so i have in one of them
there's
one million rows and the other one has
like
3.7
million rows
and each column has its d type of course
and similar to what we did before we can
see that we allocated 1.8
gigabytes of memory more or less
um
and this is how the first three rows
look like there's something nice about
polars that is not that has nothing to
do with the computation which is this
nice ascii representation that you can
copy paste uh somewhere else which is
quite cool
and you can do a describe as well value
counts so all of these are methods that
we already know from pandas
however this is where things start
getting interesting so polish
expressions work in a different way
than vex expressions so i declare them
in a generic way as you can see here i'm
doing
polars.col score and then the median so
this is not attached to a particular
data frame or a particular data set it's
something that lives on its own as an
object
and then i execute
that expression using the
dataframe.select method so i pass here
an expression
a chain of expressions and then it
returns the result
the interesting thing here is that i can
pass several expressions at the same
time so for example you can compute
what's the number of unique ids what's
the mean of the score
of the question what are the maximum
lengths of the titles things like that
and it evaluates all these expressions
in parallel
and because
the implementation is written in rust so
it's not bound to the global interpreter
log or the python semantics in any way
so you see like i got
three different results here on in a
single data frames
and
and that's it
one more interesting thing that we're
going to use now is that
polars has
expressions to work with lists of values
which i often find a little bit
cumbersome to do in pandas but with
polars it's actually quite easy
so as the last example um
you see we have the
questions data sets and the tags so if i
want to say extract all the questions
such as at least one of the tags
contains the word python
and then i
should start by doing some sort of join
however if i try to do this even in the
cloud environment that i'm in right now
it's going to fail with an out of memory
error or just kill everything
and which is not very convenient so
instead what we're going to do is to use
the lazy
api of boilers and that is as easy as
putting this dot laser here
and as soon as i do that then none of
the operations returns any intermediate
result
and
the query plan that is built is all
evaluated when we put this dot collect
at the end so again this is quite
similar to how other distributed
computing frameworks work so you have
some lazy structures and you do dot
collect or similar at the end
and i can join the questions with the
tags
quite easily and then filter which ones
have
uh any tag
lowercase containing the word python
which is exactly what i want
and this was um quite fast actually
and
interestingly if you want to
visualize how this
query plan looks like you can also do
that
so for example in this case i'm using
the scan csv function
instead of the read csv function which
returns directly
a lazy structure
and then i am calling this collect here
at the end to get the top voted python
questions so if you visualize that i
hope this is not too slow yes
and you can see how
um polars is
storing all these query plan internally
in memory
and yeah i have some more examples here
like
um
how you can work with arrays of values
and
things like that but i'm going to skip
over those because you already have them
and i'm already frying you
with information
but yeah in any ways just to wrap this
up
here i'm using the array evaluation
methods
so that i can
get very easily
lists of tags that every question has
and then go over each element of that
list so that i can do some operations
there and this allows me to to filter
the data in a different way
okay so that's it
for
the live demo everything worked i'm very
happy
oh so
what about the index this is a question
that keeps
coming up coming up james powell is not
in the audience but we've had lots of
conversations uh about this
so it's interesting that none of the
libraries that i showed arrow vex of
polars have the notion of the index
which is so central to how we work with
pandas and in fact the polars author
goes as far as saying the documentation
that indexes are not needed changed my
mind
and on the other hand
there's other people like james and
others that
advocate for the index as a way to
optimize some operations avoid
duplicating or denormalizing the data so
i think there's an interesting
discussion to be had like whether we
care about the index enough to try to
replicate it in some of the alternatives
or if we are fine with just not having
it and we can maybe change the paradigm
of how we work with data frames
so as conclusions
pandas has some limitations some
inconsistencies
and so there are projects that are
offering alternatives and although
pandas of course is here to stay for for
quite a long time
there are some dropping replacements
that um
try to offer
an alternative that you can easily
migrate to an existing code base or if
you're
your if pandas is super ingrained in
your brain
already however these are in a way bound
to imitate uh or to reimplement the
pandas api consistencies
as well
and and then there are other
alternatives that don't necessarily
offer the same api
um that
however miss some of the key features of
pandas like the index and other things
of course they're not as mature and
except from spark which is a different
case because it has its own history
outside of the by data community there
is no such alternative that
brings
this sort of
um
powerful
lazy capabilities to a distributed
computing environment so there's
something in the top right quadrant that
is still missing
um
and yeah that's it so here you have a
couple of ways to reach out to me i'll
be here for the rest of the weekend i'm
juan luz back
on twitter you can send me an email
thank you very much for kevin james
cameron richie for inspiration and
thanks to you
[Applause]
so i don't know if there are any
questions
yes thank you very much for the
presentation i wanted to
talk a little bit about using api such
as
let's say that you have data inside a
data lake let's say s3 or snowflake how
does this integrate with vex or with uh
um
with all with polars
so it's a very good question i think um
some of these libraries integrate a
project called fss spec
in python that tries to abstract
several file system
like
environments for for python such as s3
or other cloud storage um
um
yeah services
but i'm not exactly sure what's the
situation for vex and polars i initially
tried vex to read the objects directly
from s3
but as i said since they were in csv it
was converting them under the hood to
hdf5 so i abandoned that route
and then on the other hand for polars i
think it has
its own
database adapter but now the name is not
coming to my mind
so i'm not exactly sure what would be
the situation there but i think they
have it in mind and there are already
some
ways to do it
thank you
my question is on polar
like most you said about the memory map
i was wondering how does that work for
example if you have to read a sql query
if you have to read a sql query like
execute a sql query against a database
yes like panda with sql
you did see it with panda with csv but i
want to read the data from a sql
a sql database
so again i know that polars has some
database adapters
i think it's actually written in the
user guide so now that it's coming up
again i'm going to try to locate it very
quickly
um
the cookbook which is actually quite
good like i do recommend it
with postgres
yes yeah you can use directly
psychopetit too
what am i reading here yes you can
sequel where's this sequel coming from
connector x yes this is it so there's
another library it's called connectors x
that provides these
external adapters to other kinds of data
and
you can thanks to it execute a sql query
um
with a cycle pg2 connector so very
similar to what we
used to use
and use that with polars about vex i'm
not so sure
so do you have a decision tree as to in
which scenario you'd use
which of the options you said so how do
you sort of go about oh i'll use par
yeah
it's a very good question yes so
um
i included
uh i did not include that in the slides
but i should so thank you for the idea
there's a series of blog posts that i
wrote for the orchest blog so if you go
to blog orchest you will see like a much
more in-depth discussion about all this
um
but i would say that if you're looking
for an easy way to migrate from an
existing pandas code base you should use
anything on the top left corner so
either the ask modding or things like
that
and caveat supply it's distributed
computing therefore it's not one-to-one
mapping but it's nevertheless going to
make the job much easier
then if you're working on some low-level
tooling or you want to have very
fine-grained control then you should use
arrow probably
and
if you have
already some scientific data like some
huge astronomical data set or something
like that vex is probably a good good
tool for the job
and if you're not so concerned about
huge data sets or you have a way to
check them somehow but you want to try a
totally new expression system that makes
things really easy to process then you
should try polars so that would be like
my
sort of decision tree more or less so
you go up if it's distributed yeah
absolutely if you have like huge
uh
data sets that are distributed across
many files and etc you are probably
better off using dusk modding or spark
sorry say it again
that's polar that would be an excellent
replacement for this top right corner
here
for the recovering hadoopers
yeah that's actually that would have
been my question because oh i'm here
in case you're lost um like but maybe
richard answered already like is there
anything stopping me from combining
polars with the low level delayed api in
dusk and if not is that something that
you have experienced with already i
don't have experience with it but i
don't think there's nothing stopping you
from doing it and i'm looking forward to
use that kind of thing
so
thanks for the great talk
youth showed
they see the example with csv and memory
mapping it uh
do
any of these three solutions support um
uh
basically a view on a numpy array in
memory where i could have a num
gigabytes of numpy arrays in memory and
instantiate
one of these with
like polars or wax on that data and
start manipulating it also in a lazy way
thank you
it's interesting so i
don't remember exactly how the numpy
memory mapping works i know that they
have their own thing for memory maps and
i'm wondering if like the arrow
interface
would be compatible with that
like this memory map that
it's returned here it's like a file like
interface on that so if the numpy memory
mapping works in a similar way
maybe that could work however there
should be some
function that knows how to transform
that
numpy buffer data into something that
arrow understands so one of the
uh
either the streaming or the random
access format i'm not sure whether
there's a bridge between those or not
and then for the rest
i don't think so because
like polars has a much more opinionated
api so i don't think they're striving
for numpy compatibility although maybe
you could hack around
some of it and for breaks i have no idea
thanks for the talk i have a question
about paulus and if there was any
compatibility
issue with scikit-learn for example
because when yeah what i understand is
is building rust and if you want to use
scikit-learn
it's numpy behind the scene i i don't
know i i didn't try but i would like to
know if you you so
well all the psychic learn
uh forgive me about the terminology
because i'm not a cycling expert but i
think all the psychic learned
transformators and estimators they all
take numpy arrays
and
in the case of estimators possibly only
numerical numpy arrays like with no
missing values and all that
and so i don't see any incompatibility
in the sense that you can do all your
pre-processing with polar for example as
long as at some point you return a numpy
array that contains your training or
your test data
um
so yeah there should be like you can
decouple these two i would say however
at some point you have to
convert everything to numpy for second
learn to understand it i would say
excellent um thank you everyone thank
you that brings us to time if everyone
can say thank you to one